in 1865 before germany was germany it
was numerous smaller states many of
which were ruled by kings and had been
so for many centuries yet in 1871
germany was unified and all of these
kingdoms had been incorporated into the
german empire under the leadership of
the german emperor and generally in
european empires there was only room for
one royal family the imperial one which
raises the question what became of these
other german kings and their kingdoms so
in 1865 there were six kingdoms in the
german world hanover prussia saxony
voitenberg bavaria and bohemia they were
all part of the german confederation the
successor to the holy roman empire which
like that was also led by the ruler of
austria who had been butting heads with
the leaders of prussia over who was to
lead the german-speaking world these
tensions soon led to war with all of the
kingdom siding with austria over prussia
which may not have been the best choice
since prussia with the help of italy
would go on to win this saw prussia grow
to this annexing the kingdom of hanover
and thereby reducing the number of kings
to five prussian leadership had wanted
to annex saxony but given its king's
close relationship with the austrian
emperor its continued independence was a
condition for peace now the prussians
could have kept fighting but its
chancellor otto von bismarck wanted the
war over quickly because he was
concerned that france would join the war
on the side of austria which would make
things much more difficult for them as
such peace and prussia form the north
german confederation which saxony joined
the next year having previously agreed
to do so so what happened to saxony's
king well nothing the north german
confederation was a federal nation whose
states were fairly autonomous this was
because for bismarck ousting the king of
saxony would make the other kingdoms
much more nervous about joining a german
state as such the king of saxony could
stay but in return foreign policy would
be run from berlin and this framework
was in place when in 1871 these states
were added to the german empire these
three kings had mixed feelings about the
empire's creation which is why when it
was formed in the wake of france's
defeat wilhelm wasn't made the emperor
of germany but the german emperor since
the first title meant that he
technically ruled over their lands and
he was their superior whereas the second
title meant that he was the first
amongst equals obviously they weren't
his equal since brussels control over
the german empire was basically absolute
but they got to keep doing fun king
stuff so what exactly happened to them
well the smaller german kings met the
same end as the german emperor in 1918
at the end of world war one after the
kaiser's abdication and flight germany
was declared to be a republic which saw
two kings frederick augustus iii of
saxony and ludwig iii of bavaria
abdicate a few days after the emperor
frederick augustus had hoped to maintain
his position but he was unpopular and
blamed for the troubles of the war and
so off he went the last king to abdicate
was william ii of voitenberg who had
been fairly popular with his people but
the revolution across germany as a whole
meant that his position was untenable
royal titles were abolished there in
1919 and whilst they were no longer
kings they got to keep their stuff and
heard a great deal of social prestige
throughout the years of the weimar
republic but despite their high social
standing after this no king nor royal
would ever return to germany i hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with a special thanks to my
patrons james bisonette kelly moneymaker
corso wolfe jerry lamden jordan longley
adam stalter y and hockey captain cydog
rod d martin marvin castle spencer
lightfoot gustav swan common yoon
boogery wiggly matthew shipley marcus
asner the mc whopper aaron the white max
and flaurio maggie paxkowski corey
turner alex schwinn anthony beckett
spinning three plates copper tone words
about books podcast winston cayward
charles the first ben evinson and
scottish trekkie